hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem permutations
I've actually already solved this
problem before but I think I could
explain it a bit better so I wanted to
do it again we're given an array of
distinct integers and we want to return
all possible permutations of those
integers so for the record a permutation
of a set of numbers like this would look
something like this we have three
numbers so we're going to have three
positions to fill for the first position
we have three choices we can pick any of
these three elements so let's put a
three over here for the second position
we don't know which element we already
picked we could have picked this one or
this one or this one for the first spot
but either way we know we're going to
have only two elements remaining to
choose from to place over here so
there's going to be two different
elements that go here and then after
we've picked the first two elements this
one is already decided so we'll put a
one here so 3 * 2 * 1 we'll have six
different permutations of this set of
numbers and in order to visualize it
let's kind of draw a decision tree so
let's say that for the first choice we
can choose among three elements we can
have one two or three so regardless of
which path we take we're going to have
two choices here we could have either a
two or a three we can't have a one cuz
we already picked it here we can have a
one or a three because we can't have two
one or a two but not a three so now it's
going to get a bit more simple we'll
only have one choice for each of these
and it must be the element we haven't
chosen so here it's going to be three
here it's going to be two here it's
going to be three here it's going to be
one here we haven't chosen two and here
we haven't chosen one so now if you go
through each path we have a permutation
we have exactly six of them and you can
see every single one of these is
different so if we could have each of
these in an array this is the result
like we've calculated the entire result
now the only problem with the way we're
thinking about it here is it's pretty
easy on like pen and paper to draw this
out but how would we actually calculate
this in terms of code obviously it looks
like we're using recursion and it's
definitely possible to do it that way
but the way we're doing it right now
involves a decent amount of bookkeeping
because what exactly is the sub problem
like here we chose one right so we got
rid of one and these are the elements
remaining so now we're trying to create
permutations with those elements but
here the sub problem is different here
we use two so now we have the these
elements remaining and we're trying to
create permutations with those elements
again we could do it this way but it
would involve like removing this element
and doing some other stuff so I think a
slightly easier way to think about this
problem is to really use the idea of sub
problems cuz it makes recursion very
very easy so let me kind of redo this in
a very simple way now we're still going
to use recursion but we're actually not
even going to Branch anywhere so you're
going to see something interesting here
we have three numbers to choose from so
what we're trying to do is give me all
permutations from 1 2 and three but next
the sub problem we're going to ask is
this give me all permutations with just
these two numbers so we're going to have
something like this 2 three and then
finally we're going to ask just give me
all permutations with just a single
number notice how it's getting more
simple as we go down so watch what the
return value is going to be well first
let's go to the base case if I don't
have any elements from here I'm going to
return up an array with an empty list
like that's our permutation we can only
create one permutation with an empty set
of numbers and it's an empty permutation
so that's the base case just to keep it
simple and now it's going to stay pretty
simple with just three how many
permutations could we have well it would
look like this we're going to return up
to the parent just a single array with
the value three cuz a single number can
only be permutated like that
now it's going to get more interesting
from here now from this sub problem two
and three how do we solve it well you
probably know what the return value is
going to look like it's going to look
pretty simple just like this so it's
going to have two in the front and it's
going to have two in the back so 32 like
this so these are the two permutations
we can create now the reason I'm showing
you this way is this way is so easy to
calculate just watch this from the base
case all we do is just add three to that
list okay now from here this was the
numbers were given we already got all
permutations from three so now the only
thing to do is to add two so what we do
now with this array it's a very simple
array it just has one element so we know
we have two choices actually with two we
can put it at the front or we can put it
at the back so that's exactly what we do
we create a permutation with two at the
front and then we create a permutation
with two at the back and then from here
we're going to do the same thing we have
these two permutations two and three
what we're going to do is try to put one
in every position we're going to try to
put one at the beginning we're going to
try to put one in the middle and we're
going to try to put one at the end so
we're going to end up with three
different permutations we're going to do
the same thing with this one we also
have 32 it's obviously different from 2
three so we're going to put one at the
beginning in the middle and at the end
and if we do this we're going to end up
with three more permutations which is
six total permutations and that's
obviously going to be the result and if
you're curious I'll quickly draw out
those permutations here one goes at the
end here one goes in the middle oh when
I said end I meant beginning sorry here
one goes at the end and from this
permutation 32 we're going to put one at
the beginning so 1 3 2 we're going to
put one in the middle 3 1 2 and we're
going to put one at the end end 3 2 1
these are the six permutations now let's
code it up and I'll also explain the
time complexity in the coding solution
so we're going to start with the base
case which is pretty simple in our case
we're going to have the length of the
input and when it's equal to zero we're
going to return a list with a single
empty list inside of it and so the
reason we're using that is because we're
only going to have a single parameter
the input list the idea is that we're
going to keep calling the recursive
function with the input nums without the
first element so that's the sub problem
just get rid of the first element from
nums just create a subarray starting at
index one and that'll give us all the
values from nums except the first one so
these are our permutations like our sub
problem and then we want to from these
add the current element which is the
number at index zero to all of these in
every possible position and we're going
to store those in another variable which
I'm going to call result that's what
we're going to end up returning from
this function now to actually do what I
said earlier let's just go through every
single permutation that we have and for
each permutation let's go through every
possible index that we could insert the
current value into that permutation so
I'm going to get the length of P I'm
also going to have plus one because we
technically could add to the end of the
permutation as well so now for that
permutation P I'm actually going to
create a copy of it because we're going
to use this one multiple times we're
going to possibly add a value to it in
multiple different places we don't want
to modify the original permutation we
just want to create a copy of it so I'm
going to store that in a variable called
P copy then for p copy we want to insert
at index I the value nums at index zero
we're taking this value inserting it at
this index we're going to do that for
every index and then we're going to take
P copy and append it to the result we're
going to do that for every permutation
and then the result is going to be here
and then we're just going to go ahead
and return now as you can see on the
left this solution works and it is very
efficient well it's about as efficient
as we can get for this problem and let
me just kind of show you how to analyze
the time complexity the idea here is
it's going to be easier for us to do it
without kind of focusing too much on the
code remember that how many permutations
are we going to have well if we have
three elements we had something like 3 *
2 * 1 that is a math equation called n
factorial so if we have n elements in
the input we're going to have this many
different permutations how do we build
each individual permutation well to add
a single element to a permutation we're
like inserting in the middle that's how
we're coding this up so it's an N
operation and that's just inserting one
element into a existing permutation if
we're inserting n elements into each
permutation we're going to have like an
N squ over here so the overall time
complexity is going to be n factorial
time n^ 2 but this is really the
dominating factor in the time complexity
n factorial space complexity wise if
you're not counting the output which is
just going to be n * n factorial CU each
permutation is going to be of length n
and we're going to have this many of
them if you're not counting the output
and you're just counting like extra
space here the space is still actually
going to be in
factorial time n because we have
multiple copies of it here so this is
space this is time now you might think
since we don't even branch in this
recursion isn't it possible to solve
this problem without recursion and
you're exactly right the logic is going
to actually be very very similar like
we're going to start kind of with this
as the base case I think the time and
space complexity is going to be the
exact same so I guess I'll leave this
here um but this we're going to call
this our permutations and we're going to
get rid of this cuz we're not going to
have any recursion I want to leave this
code here cuz I want to show you how
similar the solution is going to be
remember this is the base case we want
to compute like the sub problem so for
every number I could use like an index I
to make it more clear but we don't need
to I'm just going to go for n in nums
for every number we want to now add this
number to all the existing permutations
that's what we're trying to do that's
the logic behind this so I'm going to
call the new permutations we create with
this number the new perms it's going to
be just an empty list for now we're
going to go through every existing
permutation kind of like we did down
here right going through every
permutation and now I want to insert
this element into every permutation and
I need to do that for every position so
I'm going to say for I in range length
of p + 1 exactly the same as we did down
here and now to that permutation I want
to create a copy of it just like we did
before and then I want to insert into
that copy the current element at index I
we want to add n so this is slightly
different I guess it's not nums of zero
it's n and also I want to say let's take
this now and add it to New perms so new
permutations append P copy the only
difference here is going to be at the
end we want to update perms to be this
now so we're going to set permutations
equal to the new permutations and then
at the end we're going to turn the
permutations so you can see that the
code above is very similar to the code
below and I kind of got rid of the base
case here so this is not like the
complete code but you can see that this
portion of the code is pretty much
exactly like this portion so I'm going
to get rid of this down here and I'm
going to run this code for you now and
show you here that it also works and
it's also just as efficient pretty much
in terms of Big O at least if you found
this helpful check out NE code. thanks
for watching and I'll see you soon